effectivement arnon bouge pas pour
encore un petit quart d'heure faux
peut-on se passer des primaires donc sur
notre plateau de la voie est libre
aujourd'hui avec philippe baumel député
ps de saône-et-loire christine robin
conseillère régionale de saône-et-loire
udi catherine hervieu vice présidente
europe écologie du camp dit jean eric
gentil conseiller régional de l'yonne
pour les républicains ont
on a déjà évoqué un certain nombre de
sujets on l'a dit au début certains
voient les primaires comme une façon de
rapprocher d'impliquer les citoyens dans
la vie politique
est ce que c'est vrai est ce que c'est
pas à double tranchant si li beaumetz
par vous que je commence l'élan de la
primaire ps en 2011
aujourd'hui un désaveu toujours plus
fort des politiques pour beaucoup de
citoyens une montée du front national
est-ce que la primaire ça marche pour ça
finalement en tous les cas ça marche
pour quand on veut donner un sens
politique à une élection c'est ça qui
est important c'est de donner la
capacité à tous les citoyens de savoir
précisément sur quoi il vote quel projet
ce qui varie les rassembler ou pas alors
après ils ont évidemment dans la merde
ce contrat qui leur est qu'ils ont passé
finalement des candidats et ça donne la
capacité évidemment de faire l'analyse
et augé il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
décalage est considérable mais après
tout c'est aussi la rançon d'une vie
démocratique
donc moi je ne je ne suis pas scandalisé
par le fait que le citoyen est cette
capacité de tri ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup plus c'est les circonstances
d'aujourd'hui qui vont présider à la
fois à cette primaire est à 7 cette
présidentielle c'est à dire évidemment
que nous sommes dans une situation
extraordinaire où jamais dans ce pays là
il ya eu autant de dévalorisation des
acteurs politiques quels qu'ils soient
que ce soit les principaux partis
démocratiques que ce soit une forme de
désespoir par rapport à ceux qui n'a pas
pu être tenu et on est dans des
circonstances extrêmes où finalement on
voit aussi remonté comme jamais une
extrême dans une extrême droite qui
devient un vrai danger pour la
république elle-même donc à une
circonstance exceptionnelle qui demande
dans tous les camps une cristallisation
forte pour être incapacité à la fois de
défendre la république et de trouver le
meilleur projet pour ce pays aujourd'hui
et qui est un peu dans l'expectative et
qui cultive une forme de dépression qui
est à mon avis en partie au fournil mais
qui est quand même très près
donc tout ça ça fait qu'on a besoin à
mon avis aujourd'hui des primaires elles
sont en risque comme toute vie politique
et démocratique est un risque parce que
c'est une forme de transparence mais il
faut jouer cette partie là sans quoi
malheureusement encore une fois s'il n'y
a pas de primaire il n'y aura pas de
rassemblement sur des enjeux essentiels
et il y aura la place au pire bien
gentil beau certains ont joué tout sauf
sarkozy la dernière fois nicolas sarkozy
envisage de participer à la primaire
est ce que c'est une façon de renouveler
la vie politique aussi si vous vous
retrouvez dans cette situation de toute
façon ça ce sont les électeurs qui
décideront du candidat
mais dans ce cas là est ce que la
primaire est un outil de rénovation de
rapprochement et de démocratisation
mais je pense que la primaire est un
outil intéressant mais si nous en sommes
arrivés là aujourd'hui c'est parce que
depuis 30 ans droite ou gauche
les personnes ont été élues sur des
programmes et ne les ont pas mis en
application et en 2017 c'est notre
dernière chance
et là on a tous une responsabilité
autour de la table il faudra que celui
qui sera élu applique son programme
l'appliquent rapidement ça peut se faire
par des ordonnances puisqu'il aura eu la
validation du peuple français il faudra
que tout de suite il
il met en place son programme et puis on
met en place toutes les mesures qu'il a
annoncées
ça passera par le parlement ça peut
passer par ordonnance parce qu'il ya
toujours un petit moment de latence
entre l'élection du président et la mise
en place du nouveau parlement
en tout cas il faudra aller vite et il
faudra vraiment faire ce que l'on aura
dit pendant la campagne électorale parce
que sinon la prochaine fois on aura
encore moins de personnes qui voteront
et plus personne ne croira ans l'homme
politique et en la politique
le scénario des primaires c'est bien
est-ce qu'il faut beaucoup plus en gros
autrement dit et vous allez toutes les
deux nous répondent à tuer ce que les
les primaires c'est suffisant s'il n'y a
pas de la proportionnelle si on passe
pas autre chose aujourd'hui
alors je vais répondre à ça mais tout
d'abord je voulais aussi rappelé
surprendra l'on compte ce que dit daigne
dany cohn-bendit quand elle parle de la
présidentielle que c'est quelque chose
qui rend fous entre guillemets mais qui
renvoie là qui qui suscite beaucoup de
deux choses un peu irrationnel sur plan
émotionnel et sur le fait que du coup au
passage on en oublie effectivement le
projet et on en oublie de faire un bilan
réel de des actions précédentes donc la
primaire par rapport à ça elle permet à
la fois de temps de tempérer cette
approche y perdent de l'hyper
personnalisation de arriver à ce
niveau-là de la vie politique à travers
cette présidentielle dorment est du
contenu et par rapport à votre question
sur la proportion la proportionnelle au
grain
il faut pas que tu as à dire beaucoup
plus bien évidemment et une enfin une
des raisons aussi pour lesquels il ya de
la déception et on s'interroge sur la
conduite du projet et tous une des
raisons c'est que la proportionnelle
n'existe pas dans enfin au niveau
national n'existe pas alors qu'elle
existe au niveau régional elle existe au
niveau municipal que ce que je sache
dans l'est dans les mairies dans les
communes et ça voilà ça suce la vie
politique issa suis pas si mal que ça
d'un point de vue démocratique au niveau
des conseils régionaux même si dans le
cadre des grandes régions voilà cessé il
ya des choses nouvelles a à faire et
enfin à se mettre en place
le scrutin proportionnel ne valide pas
une représentation démocratique
on l'a vu aux dernières élections et
malheureusement pour l'écologie sahel
toute façon donc en assumer tout donc
effectivement la primaire en soit c'est
pas c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga il faut
y mettre du contenu du renouveau
démocratique et ça passe entre autres
par la proportion c'est une roma sans
proportionnelle vous êtes obligés aussi
de négocier par exemple avec les
républicains pour exister ça en fait
partie et donc de vous poser la question
où pas d'aller dans leur commerce à
toulon ça est lié oui mais oui tout à
fait mais je voudrais rebondir sur seule
la caisse la question précédente ou à
lisier ce que la primaire ça rapproche
oui mais
les voilà le citoyen des politiques
choix qu'aujourd'hui il ya les problèmes
ils sont pas uniquement sous l'angle des
institutions ils sont aussi sur la
personnalisation des politiques en
général on sait bien que le problème
principal c'est le renouvellement de la
classe politique c'est de cela que des
citoyens saturent il ya une phase
d'exemplarité aussi un moment donné très
clairement il faut il faut qu'on accepte
de le reconnaître et je crois que le
troisième point c'est sait aussi que
effectivement il ya d'une certaine façon
il faut dire ce qu'on fait et faire ce
qu'on dit est que il ya aussi le respect
des engagements pris et ça le bain le
rôle du politique c'est peut-être
davantage de convaincre que de plaire et
qu'à un moment donné quand on s'engage à
faire des choses et qu'on est élu sur
ces sur ses engagements là bas il faut
aller au bout
même si à un moment donné ça risque de
pas faire plaisir que quelques par
l'emballement médiatique est là pour
expliquer que non on va pas être réélu
et c'est pas forcément la course aux
mandats suivants là quand même un petit
peu ce sentiment que c'est ce qui
prévaut aujourd'hui qu'on s'occupe
davantage de l'élection près du quai
devant 12 le fond d'après comment va la
faire et cela ça ouvre la porte à tous
les arrangements entre les parties parce
que bien évidemment on sait que pour
être lui dans nos systèmes
d'institutions il faut rassembler il
faut rassembler plus large et forcément
il faut des accords de circonstance
en soi c'est tout ça qui est en jeu au
delà même peut-être que simplement les
institutions qu'il faut faire évoluer
sûrement mais ya pas que ça il ya aussi
une façon dont on exerce quelque part la
politique en france est ce qu'on
pourrait pas l'exercer d'une autre
manière si par exemple le mandat de
président était unique par exemple
donc on n'aurait pas ce type ce type de
questions s'il y avait de la
proportionnelle dans les élections
législatives qui du coup ferait que la
primaire se passerait différemment
puisque on n'aurait pas à prendre en
compte un certain nombre de choses qui
vues qui vont unir derrière toujours
biaisées un peu le système c'est de
toute façon le raccourcissement du
mandat présidentiel
parce que ça a mis sa juxtaposée à
chaque fois le mandat de la des
assemblées landes avenue près et on
arrive dans un régime qui n'était pas
forcément celui qui avait été pensé dans
le cadre de la cinquième pièce ait eu si
vous regardez donc les institutions mais
aussi la façon dont les a fait évoluer
et à mon sens
voilà c'est l'hyper présidentialisation
qui conduit aujourd'hui à faire que on
est on est que dans la recherche de
l'élection présidentielle pas plus tôt
il y un conte est déjà en train de se
projeter dans la suivante on en donne et
je pense que les français en ont
ras-le-bol ils ont raison d'avoir le mal
de ça mais c'est dommage que ça fasse le
lit du fn
oui l'hyperprésidentialisation l'aviron
la vie dans ce pays on la vit notamment
depuis les modifications
constitutionnelles qui ont été votées
sous nicolas sarkozy et il faut sortir
de ça le plus vite possible
alors on emprunte d'europe la personne
était landrier salle y en a je parle
législatives il sauf qu'à des révisions
constitutionnelles qui donnent un
complice de pouvoirs aux présidents de
ces quand même sous nicolas sarkozy
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que il
faut à la fois revoir le mode d'élection
tant du président de la république très
probablement que aussi de l'assemblée
nationale on a un vrai problème de
repenser yonnais l'assemblée puisqu'il
ya à peu près 40% des choix des français
qui ne sont pas représentés aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale c'est
inacceptable parce que ça veut dire
qu'elles ne représentent pas la totalité
des citoyens français
donc il faut une véritable
proportionnelle à l'image d'ailleurs de
ce qui se passe dans les autres pays
européens
et je vois pas pourquoi on sait
exactement elle a encore dans le paysage
européen d'une règle qui part toutes
appliquées et le chaos
donc on nous rappelle à chaque fois
qu'ils aient souvenez-vous la quatrième
république
enfin iliad il ya des recettes de
proportionnelle ils font qui font que
dans un système allemand d'un système
anglais et bien on arrive à vivre la
réalité des institutions fonctionnelles
donc je pense qu'il faut écarter ce
mauvais départ
il faut avoir le souci de la
représentation il faut se poser la
question aussi de la durée du mandat
présidentiel probablement que cinq ans
c'est une erreur il faut peut-être se
poser la question de savoir s'il ne faut
pas revenir au septennat et peut-être
faut-il se poser aussi la question du
renouvellement de ce mandat parce que 6
et 7 ans peut-être comme seul mandat
suffira à ce moment-là à celui qui
pourra exercer cette mission parce qu'il
faut sortir aussi d'une d'une vision du
président de la république qui est
probablement celle que nous allons nous
avons hérité depuis la révolution
française qui est en fait d'en faire un
pseudo monarque
on n'a plus besoin aujourd'hui d'un
pseudo monarque on a besoin pertinemment
denis d'un équilibre réel des pouvoirs
qui n'existe pas sous la vème république
qui est une caricature finalement deux
républiques puisqu'en fait l'essentiel
des décisions se passe dans l'exécutif
mieux que ça au château comme on dit
c'est à dire évidemment à l'elysée on
voit bien que tous les arbitrages se
passe toujours et encore davantage
chaque sujet qui passe regardez encore
sur la loi travail ou se sont fait les
vrais arbitrage entre matignon et
l'elysée mais sûrement pas pour
l'instant
malheureusement nous le verrons je
l'espère et grâce au travail de quelques
parlementaires nous verrons si ce débat
véritablement se passer et ce choix se
passer véritablement à l'assemblée
nationale je le souhaite vivement une
jante et vous fait partie d'une nouvelle
génération est ce que vous faites partie
de cette génération est ce qu'à droite
qui a uni par de cette génération qui
souhaitent aussi faire évoluer les
institutions aller vers plus de
proportionnelle verde façon peut-être de
concevoir la prise de décisions
différemment il nous reste une minute
trente donc on va pas refaire le débat
là dessus maintenant mais on sent que
quelque chose se passe aussi dans la
société française aujourd'hui pour se
demander ce qu'il faut pas trouver des
coalitions des accords de gouvernement
qui sont pas forcément les vieilles
familles politiques
il est clair qu'il faut faire évoluer
notre constitution il faut faire évoluer
les choses
cinq ans je pense que c'est trop court
parce que tout s'accélère et en fait sur
5 ans on gouverne pendant combien de
temps réellement peut-être pendant trois
ans et le fait d'avoir des primaires ça
raccourci encore le temps donc il faut
peut-être revenir à 7 ans un mandat ou
demanda pourquoi pas un mandat le
problème c'est que on va savoir que le
président n'est là que pour cinq ans ou
que pour 7 ans et tout de suite ça va
être la course pour le mandat suivant
bon par contre moi je serais assez
favorable de limiter dans le temps les
mandats c'est à dire à trois mandats
maximum et puis également diminuer le
nombre de parlementaires
je dis pas ça de façon démagogique mais
je pense que nous avons trop de sénateur
est trop de députés pour sionnel le
permettrait à ces fascinants et alors
d'ailleurs ça peuvent permettre mais
certains veulent aussi rajouter des
députés si on rajoute de la
proportionnelle parce que je crois
également moi beaucoup à un homme un
territoire plutôt qu'à la
proportionnelle bon ce sera un autre
débat catherine avait demandé la parole
on a plus de temps se termine je suis
vraiment désolé
mais aller en quelques secondes alors
présidentielle d'en faire une fonction
symbolique et si que le gouvernement
soit issue vraiment des élections
législatives comme dans les pays
européens
ça nous donne envie d'un autre débat sur
une autre république peut-être on fera
ça une autre fois en attendant samedi
prochain le rendez vous c'est sur les
rapports tumultueux entre dijon et
besançon
bon week-end au revoir